foreign
[Music]
I gathered 100 of the largest gaming
YouTubers to be in a Minecraft Battle
Royale each team has four players in
whichever team is the last one remaining
wins 100 000 in cash start the event
where we dropping boys oh my God there's
currently a hundred creators parachuting
to the ground when I say Minecraft
Battle Royale I mean it
uh there's one Squad behind us okay we
can do this come into the brick building
Chandler behind you oh I guess I'm just
dropping right here
on the side I just got an AK as well all
right where do we go where do we go
oh there's Taylor oh I'm getting clapped
someone's in here with me I'm coming I'm
coming
I gotta create I got a weapon
oh oh I'm getting shot I'm getting shot
yo yep yep I'm going for flight going
for a flank behind you behind you who's
ever in the building
oh I just got sandwiched we got to get
better guns bail bail bail bail bail
bail I have a garbage pistol yeah we
need weapons
all right what guns we got I got AK I
only have a P90 I got p92 but honestly I
reckon we loot the whole of this airport
then we just Sprint to the middle of the
Zone yeah I am
100K no pressure 100 Grand bro oh yeah
someone just open the chest I'm just
open the chest yourself there's somebody
in there
oh my God I see a team right here
I'm dying I'm dying don't kill me
pull back pull back pull back pull back
again the loot and I'm running
oh we're so split right now wait can you
guys come to me because the other team
was around me and I don't want to leave
I'm in the hangar
oh they're looting they're looting
they're looting everyone follow me we're
gonna push the one person here oh
they're around me I can hear him moving
they're next to him hiding in this
building this building oh my God we're
rolling up on this dude guys they're on
me
I'm gonna hide behind a crate he's
upstairs maybe no he's not it
oh no okay I'm coming boys I'm coming
I got disconnected right so it's just me
sick boy sick I was robbed
what up yo yep what's up Captain
Sparkles if you sing that uh Creeper
song I might give you a sniper uh I I
used to rule the world chunks would load
when I gave the word there we go here's
a sniper yes
can you guys hear me Mr Beast give me a
gun wait techno and dream are on the
same team bro if you guys don't win
that's kind of sad oh we're gonna die
instantly you're not getting any content
out of us let's go in this building this
building we can get to the top of it
okay yeah I'm checking the top there's
nothing here come down we're let's head
to the bottom
in the building dream dream back up back
up back up I'm okay with being killed by
dream I just want just one just run come
come come come okay let's leave let's
just get away from that building it's
bad boy Halo's team pro strides and just
like in normal Battle Royale the map is
surrounded by a toxic Zone that deals
damage and is constantly shrinking to
discourage campers
the zone is closing on us but we'll just
move with it because we know nobody's
behind us so I kind of feel like we
should go to the city though yeah let's
go to the city
all right Chris we've been friends for a
while yes how do I put this there might
be another team encroaching good luck
oh
it's a team it's a team oh my God the
right hit the right hand run they've got
AKs they got a keys they're backing up
they're backing up do we want to engage
yes sir oh my God
what I couldn't move I'm healing I'm
healing I'm healing okay guys calm down
calm down go finish them off Squad wipe
them I'm gonna kill them all I'll get
revenge don't worry oh I just don't go
around the corner he's around the corner
let's go let's do it let's do it let's
do it
oh oh my God no we got deleted let's go
boys over a third of the YouTubers have
officially died and as the Zone gets
smaller and smaller things are gonna get
crazy
boys this is gonna get interesting
there's three teams on this hill and we
can Ambush them from behind that's a
huge Advantage do you guys want to go do
it all right let's do it okay go go go
go go go go oh
God Good Hits got good hits
we got him back we got him back I think
we're running different running two
teams are fighting third party of them
third party for the content
might not light them up one of them is
so low I'm getting tagged I'm getting
attacked from behind dreaming techno
dreaming techno I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead oh my God this is insane p19 I'm
going I'm going get an attack by George
guys guys guys guys go I'm chasing I'm
chasing they're so low I'm chasing too
light them up
oh they got Wilbur we'll avenge you over
I'm dead we got them Yo
oh there's techno right there clean up
this fight
I hit George I'm dying guys they're
behind us in the forest you want to go
after them yes I feel like we should
Camp I'm bloodthirsty or we could just
charge oh this is gonna be crazy it's
old Minecraft versus new you guys are
fighting Captain Sparkles
someone deciped me behind the tree oh I
just did a lot of damage oh God oh God
oh okay I'm healing
I hit techno yeah I'm getting owned they
have a sniper rifle oh I have no more I
have no more op ammo guys maybe we
should just run away I don't know yeah
let's just go back in a looting mindset
here
let's back it off so I'm running to you
guys oh you guys are on the edge of Zone
all right so confession you are getting
Snipes because I made Captain Sparkles
seeing his Rule the World song and as I
wrote I gave him one so bro oh so we get
a sniper I mean if you've seen the same
song I'll give you one I used to
rule the world chunks would load when I
gave
there you go yeah good luck
watch out it's Captain Sparkles and
quick
oh geez oh I just got shot I just got
hit for a lot um here I can give you the
oh my God where back up back up towards
the hill head towards this hill
oh I'm
a real God oh I'm about to die pressure
them they're really low they're really
low keep sniping I'm pulling keep
sniping them
oh they killed me I got sniped oh no I
would just hide we're gonna get into a
building let's head straight for this
villager
it's currently four teams camping in
these buildings at the center of the
zone I'm gonna mess things up a little
bit
why would Mr B
no that's how they all start to scramble
when they hear explosions where do we
hide let's head to the red building do
you see the red building oh yellow
team's about to stumble on orange oh
they don't even know bad I came here to
give you advice there's another team in
this building that's nice good luck uh
where are they they've got to be in the
room next to us
healing
help me help me help me
there's tons of people in the city I
want to go down and fight them yeah
let's go kill somebody I'm down with it
with that part in big time
because guys over here over here oh
another team came in oh this is all
about war no not the walls no
fudge
oh there's another team never seen on
the team back up at reload that ammo
that ammo
I'm pressing dirt
that was good I said he said back
another one another one this one just
run um
I got a kill I gotta kill no oh my God
we're doing it right here we're doing
quite well I keep forgetting that this
is for 100 grand right now
oh my God it's a war zone out there this
is the scariest experience of my entire
life we cannot leave
either scary
mommy
oh shut up oh right there right there
let's take him out oh my God they're
lazy it's on the hill on Hell get back
in together again oh gosh oh gosh
oh I got killed get inside the building
as quick as possible
show no mercy you killed me kill that
person you're right you're right we're
going in come on guys father let's go oh
right there right there right there
right there there's a guy right in here
I just saw him I just don't move there's
just one singular guy and we have to
kill him oh my God it's a full team it's
a
full story
oh my God I got rolled oh my God there's
so many
no keep going
oh I died I died we just got wiped out
I hear footsteps real close I think we
sneak our way downstairs imagine there's
another team in here camping the door
there is when we need to escape we smash
the ice and go through that Gap
hey be smart be smart it could be a
third party opportunity oh someone
bought a floor I killed someone
oh I died oh dude you shot through the
window oh dear
he's there he's there he's completely
yeah yeah oh I got him I got him I
killed Captain Sparkles Let's go baby
there's like a train we can we can maybe
get in the train should we get should we
try and get in the train careful of the
Border it's right there should we hide
because they're here guys they're right
here I think we stand here as long as we
can to use this train for cover
oh God oh God I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
wait what what I'm running I'm gonna
have to manage
no where are they
ready we have to push we have to push
right now go go here
I died oh George is dead
I gotta kill go take it home
no
oh wait there were two teams there was
that the squad wipe it's okay I gotta
kill
at this point there are only five teams
remaining and the zone is getting tiny
and every team except for not Nico are
camping inside of these two buildings
we're gonna have to move soon we're
gonna have to move soon three two one
move
okay okay we're good we're good here
we're good here guys come to the room
I'm in right here come to the room I'm
in right here because we can shoot
through this window
I found out I found out underneath
underneath the Zone's about to close
boys we're gonna get shot up when we
move ready three two one
every team has a building and then these
guys are hiding behind a light bulb wait
let's go go over here go here go over
here so you can protection right here
I fell down
oh yo I'm getting lit up
all right got him
I'm trying to fall down
we're gonna go order's coming in this
room we need to go right on Miami
oh [ __ ] we're getting murdered we're
getting slayed out
pushed out of the house we're getting
pushed out of the house it's fine we
have an officer chilling
I'll get I'm getting I'm getting here
I'm getting hit
cancel the wire there's no more
buildings to hide in they're all out in
the open oh my God fruit fruit I'm so
scared funny I'm gonna die I have to
jump
scared
oh
hold on guys guys people are on me right
now
oh no see what see what stay wide you
have this dude I have literally no cover
oh I'm dead
keep popping just keep popping
I killed him oh my God sip over is
looking good
no we're down to six who will remain
[Music]
s right here right here on the road
congratulations sip over oh my God boys
we had 22 kills just give me your
addresses I'll send you guys each 25
Grand thanks for watching subscribe
goodbye hey everybody uh I just kind of
wanted to jump in here at the end of the
video in case any of you had some
questions basically this video was
filmed a very long time ago
um but obviously when I heard the news I
kind of just was like oh one I I didn't
really know what to do with the video
and so we kind of been sitting on it but
um you know after thinking about it a
lot obviously techno loved to entertain
people you know he's just a content
creator at heart so we spoke to his
father
um he wants us to post it
um and so I thought this would this
video would be a good way to raise money
for the sarcoma Foundation but also I
just wanted to say something that I
don't think I ever really said publicly
honestly like techno was a genius
Storyteller um and I'm gonna end screen
one of his videos from his uh potato War
series when this series came out it was
literally one of my favorite series ever
I watched all three episodes just a
million times how he can take something
so insignificant and random and dumb and
make such long entertaining funny videos
around it it's hard to explain but I
want to honor him by just telling all of
you about this series I highly recommend
you watch it it is so funny and it just
really showcases how good of a
Storyteller techno is which is one thing
that I just always admired about him and
I thought he was just world class at if
you don't mind I'd appreciate if you
watch that video and rest in peace
technoblade